hey how's it going Wow oh yeah
video games sorry I got a little excited
all right so here's Tara game you're a
block and you can attach other blocks to
your block and you become a car damn and
we have a gun and we have how much [ __ ]
do we get Jesus Christ all right we are
done
let's Rick [ __ ] don't eat my flame
let's write you [ __ ] you what Oh
Tony lost his wheel my wheel [ __ ] ha ha
ha ha oh man
Tony you little [ __ ] I'm basically
like a human centipede
isn't that right how do I know this is
some work put that there then yeah that
works so well
Oh gather chemi oh well that was fast
well we look pretty bad ice I think we
need a name basically space and peace
tiny dancer
how [ __ ] dare use I wanted that name
piece of [ __ ] get a big goddamn he's
suck ass
oh god that looks dangerous is [ __ ]
should we challenge him yo will to the
watch out this area predicted by
Guardian oh god oh god
hey guardian hey I chill chillax max
relax oh cool what an [ __ ]
take a sigh him though what you gonna do
now [ __ ] oh my god I'm so awesome
let's just let him stay there and think
about what he did you did
oh my god so much stuff so much stuff
don't explode don't explode come to my
butt okay that's pretty badass you know
what that's pretty [ __ ] bad
hahaha die [ __ ] ah he shut off my
laser Wow Bessie Bessie
girl who's the Guardian now huh
uh ranked multiplayer yay here we go now
this is what I call a base city beast
how do I control it Hey he's fighting
what that can't lose I'm so big this is
[ __ ] oh my god I hate this game
Oh oops
hey pesky Beast I can't do anything all
right that that's fun yay video games
they like if you don't watching buzz and
as always thank you for watching stay
awesome bros oh mama me I am NOT going
energy we go out there up in the heat
can we go a spell's are you'll go fight
Bowser
[ __ ] at the boughs camera my